hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan where I
answer your questions today I'm gonna
answer a question from Valerie who's
asking about how to set up a home-based
business so she wrote in saying hi Evan
and it's kind of a long email but she's
from the Netherlands and she wrote in
the reason why I wanted to personally
mail you is because I'd like to ask if
you can give me advice and what I can do
to start my own business from home so
thanks for the question Valerie it's a
great question a lot of people are
having that that same question for their
own thinking either to have a full-time
business from home or something to
support yourself part-time there's a lot
of opportunities I think the thing you
want to look at though is make sure it's
something that you're really passionate
about and this is where most
entrepreneurs will fall down the look at
different home-based business ideas or
network marketing opportunities and it's
not necessarily anything wrong with them
it's just that it's got to be something
that you believe in most people pick up
a product or start a business because
they're trying to make a lot of money
and if you look at the most successful
entrepreneurs they didn't start their
business to make a lot of money it's a
byproduct of being successful but they
started their business because they had
a strong passion for what they're doing
and they really wanted to help people so
you can make money in any industry and
you can make money from home and in the
industry the key though is that you're
doing something that you're really
excited about and you feel you can tell
your own story and and really help other
people so look at any of those products
look at what you're already using and
see if there's any way that you can
promote that online do they have an
affiliate program that you can sign up
for on the web if you're looking at
different home-based opportunities that
are online you want to look at is this
something that has some meaning to you
right when you're trying to promote
something online you want to be able to
tell your story and how it's helped you
and how it can potentially help others
if you're just you know spamming people
it's not gonna really have a lot of
impact and you see a lot of the guys who
don't have success with network
marketing or home-based businesses it's
because they don't have a true
connection to what they're doing they're
just trying to make money but they're
not really actually helping people so
look at where you solve frustrations for
yourself in the past how you been able
to help other people in the past and how
you can potentially continue to do that
from home
or online in a meaningful way and from
there you'll be able to generate a
business so I'm sorry I can't give you a
specific answer to say go start this
business because it really depends write
the business out that I would be
successful I'd is probably different
than the one that you would be
successful at because we have different
interests different passions but it's
got to be something that you're really
strongly passionate about you care
deeply about and you feel you can have
added value to other people and make a
meaningful difference in their lives for
me I love helping entrepreneurs and so
everything I do almost is around helping
entrepreneurs I make these videos I do a
lot of stuff on the web a lot of stuff
you don't even get paid to do it it's
just because I really have a strong
passion to help entrepreneurs it's what
gets me going in the morning I love
seeing responses come in and and knowing
that I'm having an impact helping people
with their businesses for you it could
be something completely different right
maybe you love recipes or you love cats
or you love helping people with
insurance or whatever it is a lot of
different opportunities out there but
it's got to be something that you really
feel strongly about and you want to be
able to make and impact on and it's not
only gonna make you a lot of money it's
also gonna be really rewarding because
you're doing something that you care
about and you know you helping other
people so hopefully I helps Valerie
thank you for tuning in all the way from
the Netherlands for those of you
watching if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up below and makes fun
of do more of these videos for you guys
and I love to hear we have to think
about Valerie's question or if you have
a question of your own if you want leave
it in the comment section below I always
read those I really look forward to
seeing them so hopefully you'll leave a
comment and we'll see you on the next
episode